foreign
how's Alice doing you okay Alice
I have to ask is this you forever
I don't know
I always had in the back of my head
writing a show about a physician or a
therapist that was kind of dealing with
grief excuse me so up Jimmy hey Gabby
and I had an idea for a show that was
basically a very very dark version of
what this show is
[Music]
did you pay the money
not yet
and he said why don't we put these
together
we met with Jason and we talked about
this idea for the show and then I
thought very soon after he said yeah I
want to do this with you guys you meet
Jimmy truly at Rock Bottom he's grieving
the loss of his wife
you've been acting like it only happened
to you but it happened to us Jimmy has
really Fallen apart and is no longer a
Dependable parent you know the most
important person in your life is you
your daughter right that's what I meant
second
okay
because of his grieving things reach a
boiling point you guys don't get so mad
at your patients I get sad would I do
this thing maybe don't do that thing
Jimmy decides to start telling patients
exactly what he thinks what sets you off
everything you trust me Sean no it
doesn't matter let's go find you someone
to beat up
he could use his feet he's shot he's
using his feet he's gonna use his feet
the whole time I bet I know that
if you don't feel any grief or
heartbreak then you've missed the point
of what it means to be alive sometimes
you're crying and it's very surprising
but it's very funny
I'm so sorry how are you already crying
so hard oh no I was crying before
[Music]
throughout the season we watched Jimmy
clumsily figure out how to rebuild be me
for a second sorry for always being so
hard on you
it's only because I love you I don't
talk like that
it's the Journey of reconnecting with
all the people that surround him I was
there I needed to hit rock bottom and
you wouldn't want me a really
interesting theme of the show is by
helping others we can somehow heal
ourselves when there's a big cloud of
Darkness sometimes the only thing that
can yank you out is making each other
laugh man this thing I'm doing is really
working
[Music]
I need you to be excited for me
I love you
too much yes I know take a chance with
me
[Music]